deutschlands innenstädte sind voll von
ihnen smartphone usern die über
messenger services textnachrichten und
emoticons verschicken besonders beliebt
whatsapp darüber versenden user manchmal
mehrere hundert nachrichten pro tag
einzige voraussetzung ein zugang zum
wlan oder eine datenflatrate einfachsten
einfach nachrichten verschicken uns
sachen ausmachen
die gruppen chat möglichkeiten sind
super zeit einmal viel schneller ist und
weil es auch kostenlos ist 80 prozent
meiner kommunikation die nicht
telefonisch es natürlich verläuft oder
persönlich von whatsapp raspail reiz ist
dass man sehen kann ob die menschen
gelesen haben oder nicht es ist schon
cool
das us unternehmen ist mit 450 millionen
usern marktführer gefolgt von rochat aus
china mit 270 millionen kunden
und über den japanischen dienst leisten
rund 200 millionen nutzer der berliner
netz experte markus beckedahl beobachtet
den wettbewerb der messaging dienste
er weiß warum viele junge user
klassischen sozialen netzwerken den
rücken zuwenden
der vorteil von messenger diensten ist
und sie einfach auf das rudimentäre
beschränken kann nämlich kurznachrichten
mit anderen teilen immer auf dem
laufenden sein was andere machen mit
weniger selbstinszenierung vor einer
großen gruppe sondern in der regel in
kleinen gruppen oder einem persönlichen
gespräch im februar 2014 verkündet
facebook chef mark zuckerberg den kauf
von whatsapp für umgerechnet 13,8
milliarden euro dieses geschäft selbst
ein deutliches zeichen
jeder der 450 millionen whatsapp kunden
ist in rund 30 euro wert whatsapp könnte
in zwei jahren mehr nutzer haben als
facebook selbst insofern hat man quasi
die letzte chance genutzt einen
aufstrebenden konkurrenten aufzukaufen
und natürlich hat facebook ein großes
interesse daran diese daten die dort
gesammelt werden weiterhin in sein
eigenes ökosystem reinzutragen um das
eigentliche geschäftsmodell zu
bestreiten nämlich geld zu verdienen
indem werbung verkauft wird besonders
die deutsche netz gemeinde reagiert
darauf misstrauisch viele user wechseln
zu alternativen messenger apps doch
nicht alle sind unbedingt besser
die stiftung warentest hat fünf
messaging-dienste getestet bestnoten gab
es dabei für prima das schweizer startup
freut sich derzeit über täglich 100.000
neukunden die schätze vor allem die
verschlüsselung ihrer nachrichten
gesendet keinerlei daten unverschlüsselt
und sie sind keinerlei daten an drittel
das ist ganz wichtig mit der und mit der
verschlüsselung ist es so dass es eine
so genannte ende zu ende verschlüsselung
ist das heißt selbst der anbieter also
frima die chats nicht mitlesen kann
also können sie auch keine daten später
verkaufen bei whatsapp steht die
mangelhafte datensicherheit aber
offensichtlich nur wenige user weltweit
kommen täglich mehrere hunderttausend
neue kunden dazu ich habe auch schon
überlegt zu wechseln aber es ist halt im
moment dieses alle haben es nach
ich hab telegramm schon aber zu wenig
nur zu machen bei mir sitzen möchte so
dass ich nicht groß war zu verbergen
habe ich habe nicht so private bilder
ich denke mal wenn man sich da bei
facebook angemeldet hat oder auch bei
whatsup dass die ganzen daten dafür
immer gespeichert haben
ich habe nichts zu verheimlichen wenn
jetzt irgendwie die nachrichten lesen
würde würde ich mich jetzt nicht schämen
ich möchte jetzt mal mehr überlegen und
nachdenken und vielleicht doch wechseln
noch stimmen die nutzerzahlen von
whatsapp trotzdem sollte der
messenger-dienst das vertrauen seiner
nutzer nicht verspielen
sonst platzt die blase shift meint traut
euch zu wechseln